donovan mcnabb has made the case for
himself to make it to the pro football
hall of fame that's always less
persuasive than someone else making the
case for a guy to get to the hall of
fame so how about his former head coach
andy reid reid said earlier this week of
donovan mcnabb listen i'm his biggest
fan now listen he never begins
a sentence in response to a question
without starting it with the word listen
listen i'm his biggest fan i was there i
know he belongs there you talk about the
great players in the national football
league five championship games a super
bowl all those things good football
player great football player and did
some things that weren't being done at
that particular time in a lot of areas i
think the world of him i'm not surprised
the guy who drafted me and coached him
thinks he should be in the hall of fame
it's like asking his mom should he be in
the hall of fame i'm a firm believer big
cat he shouldn't be in the hall of fame
for quarterbacks i got four categories
i've got statistics longevity
championships and dominance and in my
mind donna mcnabb satisfies none of
those he didn't play long enough he
isn't high enough on the all-time list
he has no super bowl win he was never a
league mvp he was never a truly dominant
player and that's enough you don't get
in holla the very good as some call it
not hall of fame yeah i would agree with
you hall very good i think he also has
the uh problem where his success in the
early rounds of the playoffs hurt his
resume somehow he has not you know nine
i think playoff wins but the fact that
he only went to one super bowl lost that
super bowl hurts him and your last point
is the one i always stick to if you
think a player if you think donald
mcnabb was he ever the best quarterback
in the nfl and i'm not even talking
about mvps because sometimes that goes
you know there'll be a guy who wins an
mvp but you still think of one guy for
that year there's never been a year that
donald mcnabb was the best quarterback
he got stuck in that weird zone
where he got the tail end of brett favre
he got this you know start of peyton
manning tom brady and uh you know then
you get other guys coming are coming
around drew brees phil rivers so he
never had that one year where he was the
best quarterback i actually looked it up
2004 was his best statistical year
peyton manning was better
your guy dante culpepper culpepper was
better and that hurts that hurts when
you can't look at one season you want to
make the argument for like a terrell
davis remember charles davis was the
best running back in the nfl for a
three-year stretch there kurt warner he
was the best quarterback for actually
two different stretches there so not
having that one you know year you can
point to and say that was donovan
mcnabb's year that was his transcendent
year takes him out of this hall very
good for me as well and and you know why
he was so good in 2004. he was so good
in 2004 because of terrell owens plain
and simple who was absolutely dominant
it is criminal that he did not get into
the hall of fame on the first try one of
the best receivers of all time and
helped donovan mcnabb immensely
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports